they'll always have their phone on them  okay like every single human being on  planet earth has their phone on them you  ask them to take their phone out or and  then you say cool what bank do you bank  with and then they'll say whatever bank  they bank with they're like cool can you  pull up your banking app real quick and  they'll be like okay cool go to  statements as soon as they go to  statements you say cool there you go you  can click any of the months it doesn't  really matter and on the top right  you'll see your account number and so  right there it's the full account number  for their account and you can write that  down in lieu of a credit card it's an  ach transaction if you can't do acs  transactions you should get that set up  with whoever processes your money  because it opens up another way for you  to make a sale if you're enjoying these  tips and tricks and you want more  in-depth content go to the youtube video  and check out all the good stuff that we  have there